bonjour alors vous qui vous trouvez sur
place expliqué nous quelle est la
situation ce matin
bonjour on est sur place depuis que
cette catastrophe est arrivé là
aujourd'hui on a pas mal d'huile qui est
encore là analyse volonté d'une veste et
maurice comme je suis président d'une
ong
on a en mobiliser tous notre équipe on
est là on est en train de nettoyer
nettoyer toutes les lignes 6 et aussi
les plastiques tout les débris qu'on
peut sincèrement parce qu'il ne veut pas
que ça mélange avec lui le si à la fin
on a plus de ce type de wisco comblant
jury alors c'est une course contre la
montre qui est engagée sur l'île est ce
qu'on peut éviter une catastrophe
écologique qu'elle est déjà l'impact sur
l'écosystème
oui c'est une course contre la montre
au fait on l'a on a les équipes ici on
veut on veut protéger les manguiers qui
sont pas encore affectés
c'est pourquoi on est en train de
mobiliser aujourd'hui on a presque 200
étudiants qui est déjà sur place
on est en train de placer ce boom 6
annales qu'on appelle l'étude de public
mauricien est là et nous aide et tentera
aussi de placer le soutien alors on a vu
ces images à près de 3,6 kilomètres de
barrages flottants en chanvre est en
tissu qui ont été construits en grande
partie vous le rappeler à l'instant à
part des amines et de volontaires pour
tenter de circonscrire la nappe est ce
que c'est efficace est ce qu'on peut
faire autrement plus efficacement oui
c'est efficace c'est depuis car bien sûr
on le fait on les place à chaque course
line près du des mangues lié tout ça est
aussi mais c'est plus pratique quand ses
prêtres et de la terre comparées sur
place en haute mer parce que ça va ça va
briser avec les vagues mais ça ça nous
aide beaucoup à contrer cette news ou
qui déverse près du mobile le bateau a
échoué le vin en juillet dernier
pourquoi est ce que les opérations de
nettoyage ont-elles tant tardé
en fait ce que je comprends pas c'est
moi en tant que lecture est aussi
présente chez on n'est pas trop de ce
côté là c'est que je compris on a tout
un protocole à suivre pour pouvoir
pomper cette huile de ces bateaux là
mais là comme la catastrophe est déjà
causé là on s'est mobilisés pour
nettoyer tout ce qui est dans les côtes
mauriciennes
cette pollution est définitive alors oui
ça prendra beaucoup de temps à nettoyer
et il faut propos monitoring system pour
bien gérer
peut-être prendra beaucoup moins quand
messi en titre dans ce domaine là je
crois ça pour avoir beaucoup de temps
pour plus de dix ans pour que ça puisse
vraiment aller leur écosystème
alors la société japonaise propriétaire
du bateau a présenté hier ses profondes
excuses au peuple mauricien dans un
communiqué s est engagé à faire son
maximum pour protéger l'environnement et
atténuer les effets de la pollution
le bateau voyager à vinyle transporter
200 tonnes de diesel 3800 tonnes d'huile
lourde
est ce que ces excuses sont suffisantes
au regard de cette catastrophe
écologique
je suis dans ces sites dans l'est depuis
2009 contre en ce pont en est on arrive
notre hit corail on se transporte les
coraux j'ai tout une équipe lion's club
de flaques qui nous aide aussi
c'est ainsi que je connais depuis 2009
là je n'ai pas encore commencé mon
assesment être pouvoir une reprise en a
environ 15000 boutu à koro déjà prêt à
transporter ou moins c'est la
catastrophe mais le propos le problème
le bateau est déjà là ils ont présenté
leurs excuses mais en tant que citoyen
maureen si si et si on this qui est
vraiment dévoués pour cette
réhabilitation sept sites qu'on a déjà
commencé 2009
ça fait mal au coeur c'est vrai mais le
mal est déjà là et ils ont présenté les
excuses mais attendons la suite
maintenant ou réhabiliter tout ce qui en
a détruit ce bartula et alors qu'elle
regardait ce que vous portez est-ce
qu'on doit laisser naviguer en mer dans
des eaux protégées comme celle là dit
l'humoriste des bateaux qui transportent
des matières aussi polluante
bon ça c'est ce que j'ai compris c'est
l'huile que le bateau doit utiliser
il n'y a pas d'autres moyens mais on a
pas de boîte ou vraiment qui est un 100%
cela ou quelque chose comme ça et
maurice me positionne à un point
stratégique où on a pas mal de bateaux
qui qui passent dans notre e
mais on doit s'équiper on doit s'occuper
au manque pas mal d'équipements mais là
on a on à cette pourriture doit
s'équiper ou éviter ce type de
catastrophe
à maurice alors les habitants de l'île
où le rappel dépendent de ces deux de
ses hauts pour la nourriture lille tire
notamment ses ressources du tourisme est
ce que c'est aussi une catastrophe
économique
bien sûr si on a pas mal dépêcher si les
plaisanciers
on a sept parties de l'insee c'est pas
un petit plus beau je peux vous dire on
a c'est très prisé par les mauriciens
pas le touriste c'est très prisée en
harley quinn des coraux qui sont en et
s'en sont vraiment extrêmement une
beauté ici mais on ne sait pas à l'heure
parce qu'on n'a pas commencé cette cette
partie assez semaine qu'est ce qu'on a
détruit mais c'est mes bien chers
bien sûr ça va affecter l'économie ainsi
tout laisse de bons résultats merci
beaucoup d'avoir un prix temps de
répondre à nos questions l'ademe la
nationale et je rappelle que vous êtes
notamment chargé de cours à la faculté
des études océaniques à l'université de
maurice